[Music]
okay all right so yeah we just like to
present on project we've been working on
combining a bit of open data and Python
so Andre is going to present with me and
another colleague of ours who can't be
with us today unfortunately she's been
contributing as well so we all work for
a company called how 24k which operates
since working on smart cities problems
so anyway yeah I try to you also be the
microphone would help but so does that
better yeah
so that so since we're in London the the
top five causes of death in London were
published in 2012 in quite a lot of
detail for all the barrels of London and
you might be surprised to hear that
dementia and Alzheimer's disease
appeared in the top five for both male
and female causes of death and whilst
there may be different reasons for this
you might be surprised to hear that it
could be air pollution that's
contributing to dementia as a cause of
death
so our attention was drawn to a couple
of articles and papers towards the end
of last year beginning of this year you
can look them up there's a good one
there I've got a post at the link at the
bottom showing that there's there's a
some kind of link between traffic
related pollutants and cognitive decline
in both the the brain development and
young and cognitive decline in the
elderly so whilst the link between sort
of lung disease and so forth and
pollutions is quite clear this this is
quite a relatively new discovery so a
bit of background so dementia
and Alzheimer's disease specifically
Alzheimer's disease is the most common
form of dementia and it's progressive
neurodegenerative so it's mean is the
cellular structure of the brain changes
in the case of out Symonds it's this
accumulation of plaques that takes 15 to
20 years and after this you get this
these clinical symptoms which start with
memory issues and lead on get worse and
worse up to death and death is not easy
it's not quick it's traumatic and it's
it has a huge impact on surrounding
families we don't we now understand the
cause of dementia its genetic and
environmental factors and I guess the
only thing we know for sure is that it's
that it's related to old age so that
means that because of changing
demographics this the global age group
of 60 years plus is going to be the
biggest age group in 2050 so the burden
is going to increase so it's like this
paradox of modern medicine we live
longer and longer but we do so with more
diseases and I saw a TED talk which kind
of Illustrated the impact of this so if
you if you look at every else in the
room and imagine we're all 85 you can
look at two people in the room one of
them will have Alzheimer's or dementia
and if you haven't got dementia then
you're probably going to be a caretaker
for one of the others if you're going to
imagine that so the impact is huge and
it's probably going to biggest killer of
the 21st century it's been predicted so
who are we so as I mentioned earlier
Andre Esther myself we all work for
health 24k which is operating in smart
cities space so we don't do any work on
dementia but we do look at air quality
and emissions as part of our work so
this is a this is really a side project
why are we interested in this well
myself I've got my grandparents on one
slide past one of them passed away and
one I'm still suffering from Alzheimer's
so it may be interested in
looking at dementia data Esther's study
PhD in neuroscience and Andre well
Andres lived in a lot of polluted cities
so he's work also so how does these
articles and Patos would be published
how does how to pollutants affect the
central nervous system so the general
idea is that the two routes to the brain
via the nose nasal passages and via the
bloodstream and it's not there's a lot
of pollutants in the air around us
especially here if you walk outside but
it's the really fine particles PM 2.5
it stands for particulate matter 2.5 so
it's less than 2.5 micrometers in
diameter that gives you an idea of the
scale that's a human hair and a few
grains of sand so the blue particles are
these are like pollen which is really
annoying summer for some people and the
Reds are even smaller so it's yeah 2.5
microns diameter the first ways of
classifying these particles made of lots
of different chemicals and materials
that you can roughly categorize them as
human-made and non-human made so
human-made would be anything from
industry vehicles cars lorries
agriculture a non human made or a non
anthropogenic would be forest fires and
sort of thing there's a few links there
if you need to look up and read from
Defra and the government department they
talk a lot about the particles so a
component of this PMC 0.5 is this black
carbon which so a lot of these particles
from vehicles diesel emissions and this
is this is a map in 2009 in the UK so
you can see that it's really it's all
about the roads where the roads are and
it's this is creating up to 30 40 % of
the particles so seeing this map made us
wonder if living in aa narrow city means
you have an increased chance of
contracting out sinus disease so we just
went to look at that that's so that yeah
just a low view what what the talk is
about so we're just
if we can use open data to sort of
determine the link between out summers
prevalence and air pollution ourselves
we wanted to on the way we discovered a
few nice visualization techniques in
Python that other is going to talk about
and also yeah this is still
work-in-progress
so we're going to discuss some of the
sort of hurdles we had and also findings
that we've had so far really yeah so we
went to collect some data air quality
data in so we chose the three countries
that our company is based in because we
thought that would be easy to tell of
their quality challenges because the
data formats quite different and the way
it's monitored is quite different we
wanted to get cumulative PM 2.5 over a
lifetime obviously but monitoring
stations have really only been set up
since in the UK since 2009 a decent
network and never think it was 2011 I
think and the u.s. in California
slightly earlier in 1990 but so we chose
a five year period of cumulative PM 2.5
particles because we could get hold of
so monitoring stations for PM 2.5
they have different densities depending
on which area so you can see that
Californian seems to be well covered
with monitoring stations less so Nevada
although Las Vegas seems to have a
monitoring station it seems to gone off
the scale so maybe that's why they don't
have any monitoring stations in Nevada I
don't know yeah that's another reason
yeah so yeah that was just a test to put
in there thank you so a Netherlands in
the UK the UK seems to be have a lot of
multi stations but they're focused on
urban areas cities mainly but the
Netherlands very well covered apparently
and and if you see my own cities the
story's a bit different actually London
and Amsterdam are have a decent number
of monitoring stations it's been a lot
of in London that's more and more
awareness about air quad
see so that's why there's a decent
monitoring network San Francisco only
appears to have one monitoring station
though in their network that we belong
to the EPA so kind of more limited
coverage there so yeah I've got the air
quality data we wanted to dive into the
Alzheimer's prevalence data that we
could get hold of so three countries
were different years but as close as we
could get regional divisions are
obviously very different and the age
resolution was quite different so
without further ado I'm going to hand
over to Andre and you can talk about
visualization hey there we go almost
there
okay okay can anybody hear me cool so
yeah thank you Frank hopefully I will
not destroy your computer like with max
I'm afraid of max because how do i ah
yes okay so after this crash course into
our data I thought we could spend the
next couple of minutes actually looking
into some tools that help us analyze and
visualize this data now you know to keep
it in the context of the talk the
examples I will be showing to you has to
do with the data model and actually yes
you can see them out there excellent so
the data of the Netherlands and that's
that's what we will be doing now this
demo is supposed to be kind of quick so
that we have time to talk about the
results so you can go and download this
notebook I put it on github and the link
is in the select channel for this talk
so you can go and check it out yourself
this is also my excuse to skip over
parts that I deem slightly less
interesting and give you a homework so
sorry about that
so yeah let's also yeah the demo is a
kind of quick but I included some
other resources that you can go to and
get more detailed information about how
all of these works so now we can get to
it and so the tool I will be talking
about the most is this G appended
library which is a library to help you
analyze this geospatial data so data
with some geographical information in in
it now as the name suggests this is
supposed to work like pandas so if you
know pandas yourself a lot of this stuff
and lot of what geo pandas does will be
very familiar to so let's look into it
we import some stuff and set some
parameters and we read in the data now
we read the data from the shapefiles
dot SHP now on friday if you went to the
to the geospatial workshop they
mentioned that it exists but then they
went another way so this is the this is
the shape file way so we read the file
into this geo data frame this is the gdf
and the weird word in front of it is
commentor which is which is how the
dutch call like their counties so that's
how it's called I just look at the how
it looks like so one line for each of
these regions just as we are used to
from pandas and importantly we have this
geometry column which gives us the
borders of each of these regions in this
in this polygon object so to just have
an idea how this might look so this is
one of them just a shape like that
however they can be more complicated
just like this in this case you'd be
talking about the multi polygon so we
have like the bigger landmass and an
island and even like a hole like a lake
or something like that so this is great
now another great thing about the Geo
data frames in general is that they know
how to plot themselves now this is
similar to the pandas data frames so if
I just call plot here I can create a map
actually how do I make it fullscreen no
this is not how I make it fullscreen
okay I will not try to do that but you
can probably recognize at least a bit
the Netherlands a simple net divided
into this individual
counties now the color scheme is
debatably horrible but since this is not
cloud lip you can use all the commands
and tricks that you do and make well a
less ugly or more ugly map but the
important thing is freedom it's all up
to you so great this is how our data
looks like and now let's look at some
examples of how geo pandas can help us
analyze it so the first example that we
will be talking about is making these
choropleth maps which is just a fancy
way of saying that we will be coloring
the individual region by a certain
property now in this particular example
we will be creating a map of the
alzheimer prevalence or dementia
prevalence in the Netherlands now this
is quite a straightforward task because
we have the data so we read in into this
time pandas dataframe from a CSV file
and again we get for each of these
counties a lot of information including
the Alzheimer prevalence in person right
here so this is great now in this cell
we perform the usual merge that we are
used to from 10 dots and we can do the
plotting now all of this is what we have
already done with the exception of of
this part where we give where we specify
a column that we want to plot so this is
the Alzheimer prevalence and some other
parameters as the color and so on and lo
and behold we have a map of the
Alzheimer prevalence in in the
Netherland now this is just a demo for
the visualizing tool so we will Frank
will later talk about what all of this
means and how to deal with this but this
is our result so great we know how to
create these kind of maps now let's look
another example namely the spatial
joints now this is another quote
powerful tool that geo pandas allows you
to do this is similar to the joint that
pandas does and that we just did where
you pick like two columns that you want
to merge on
however the spatial joints uses the
properties of the of the
shape objects of the polygons and so on
and allows you to for example join on
all the older lines where the regions
overlap or the regions where one lies
within the other and so on and we'll be
using this to create a similar map of
the air pollution in the Netherlands so
first we read in all the data now for
the Netherlands this is actually this is
a super detailed so this is how it looks
like
you can probably recognize what the
Netherlands some of the road network
this actually is based on a simulation
but the simulation comes from the actual
measurements and this is essentially
just a numpy matrix which gives you a
resolution of 1 by 1 kilometer and each
of these smaller regions for each of
these smaller regions then you have the
value of the of the air pollution so the
PM 2.5 the particulate matter that Frank
was mentioning so the first thing that
we need to do here is to well assign the
geographical coordinates to each of
these like I said this is just a numpy
array so this is this is done in this
cell and actually it's not that
important for this demo so again you can
go and check what is done yours what is
done here yourself I try to comment it
in a reasonable way but on the other end
we get another geo data frame here PM
geo data frame so particulate matter
that looks like this so now you have
points in the geometry column the
coordinates the numbers there are the
coordinates in this Dutch specific
coordinate system but you can easily
transform it into latitude and longitude
if you want but for each of these points
which is the center of each of the 1 by
1 kilometre regions you have the PM 2.5
value so excellent this allows us to
perform the spatial join which we are
doing right here and this is how it
looks like it's very similar to the to
the pandas merge that we are used to we
are merging the air quality and regional
geo data frame and how exactly are we
doing it well we want to join everywhere
where the air quality measurement lies
within one of the counties so this is
how it works actually this is just a
part of the job because this then
essentially gives you a lot of
individual measurements for each of
these counties but in this line we just
take the mean for each County and we are
we are left with this kind of data where
for each of these County codes in this
case you have the average measurement of
the air pollution and so just like
before you can merge it back into the
original geo data frame so we've already
seen all of this at the very beginning
and now we've created this new column PM
2.5 or PM 25 in this case but it's 2.5
and just as before we can plot it and
here we are the map of the average air
pollution or PM 2.5 in in the
Netherlands again frame will tell you
what all of this means now the the
notebook continues a bit more and again
I encourage you to download it and go
through it I will kind of stop here so
we can actually talk about some of the
results it talks about how to turn into
this static kind of figures from not
public into something a bit more
interactive so it talks about examples
of three libraries one of them is MPL
leaflet which allows you to quickly
export the map into a leaflet style map
and you can get something like this you
can zoom in zoom out and so on it talks
about volume which allows you to create
something similar and also you can have
this like pop-ups so when you click on a
comment or well in one of these regions
you get the actual value and also there
is an example of Boquete which many
people already talked about which among
other things gives you the power of this
hover tool so when I point somewhere it
gives me the name of the region and
the measurement again so this match for
the demo I'm handing off back to Frank
and yet deal with your computer and I
hope so yeah
there you go I thought
okay oops
so yeah thanks for the chat about dear
pandas and a bit of okay there at the
end so looking at our data as Andre
showed this was the cumulative a PM 2.5
count over four years we managed to
gather in the Netherlands as you can see
it's confined like the highest levels of
the darkest and it's confined to the
south of the country and this made us
think of it looks familiar and then we
found the average wind profile in the
Netherlands again and it seems to match
very well so I think if I can I can show
you actually don't forget about that
actually so there is a link there if you
want to click and you can see the
effects of wind on PM 2.5 particles in I
think it's in Beijing so it has a huge
impact so perhaps a small tip if if you
want to live in a and out of a cleaner
area choose a place that's quite windy
although in the case of Beijing it's the
winds can actually blow the pollution
into the city at times so it's may have
a negative effect so we then looked at
dementia prevalence and this is just
straight up dementia prevalence in the
country which the problem with that is
it's really the same as the age
distribution across the country so this
isn't the a the median age it's the the
fraction of the population in each
region that's over 65 so you can see
that it closely matches the dementia
prevalence as you'd expect so doesn't
really tell us anything useful it just
sort of thing to be careful of so what
you need to do is adjust for age it's
fairly straightforward I mean you could
Google on how to do it but the the crux
of it is just really mapping all of your
pregnancies in each age range for each
region on to a sort of standardized
population profile and you can download
examples from the World Health
Organization websites so
juster you are then able to compare
different regions even if the age
distribution is entirely different sort
of on a side by side basis so if we then
so then with the Netherlands data we we
had the PM 2.5 that's fine
we kind of crudely adjusted the dementia
data just using the fact that because we
didn't know any sort of breakdown of the
dementia data itself we just knew the
proportion of people over 65 in that
county they didn't really give us
anything useful and we can't see any
sort of major patterns emerging and when
we when we just plot a sort of
correlation
sorry scatter plot there's no real
correlation there as we could see we had
look at the California data that was in
some ways even worse than the Dutch data
so so they've got DMC 0.5 but the thing
is that yeah the monitoring stations in
California weren't very evenly spread at
all so we're kind of and all of the
counties got missing data as well also
the dementia prevalence was a bit odd in
that it was just for Medicare
subscribers so but they were it was is
like a severe case of what's known as
sample bias so he doesn't really reflect
the underlying population and plus we
didn't have any detailed age breakdown
so we just knew the proportion over and
under 65 so people who obviously sign up
for Medicare are going to be tending to
be older and probably more ill than the
rest of the population so it wasn't
particularly useful
so yeah just summarizing the limitations
with the Californian and Dutch data
there so we decided to just move on and
and have a look at the UK data so the
British data actually was decent
resolution slight challenge the UK we
like to define our boundaries very
particularly and so you have the
dementia account by parliamentary
constituency and of course the pollution
data was by local authority
and in the UK so we have these very odd
we have like ceremonial counties and
different kind of divisions and that if
you get a chance then you need
shapefiles go to the Ordnance Survey
website they have very good very easy to
understand interface and you can just
download all the shape files you need if
you want to do any kind of geospatial
analysis
so here's here is plotting the
human-made PM 2.5 in London and as you'd
expect it's pretty high in center sort
of some of the highest levels in the
country and this is cumulative of 5
years and this is by local authority
when we plot dementia prevalence the
region the boundaries are can be
different so it's quite hard to compare
of it you can sort of get a general gist
oddly so that looks like there's less
dementia in the centre of London I'll
explain why in a minute so so live in
the TEL alone if you want to reduce your
chance of dementia according to this map
this is the the sort of we then did as
andre explain these geospatial joins so
you can see that we had to go with this
sort of overlapping of different regions
so we've got a solution age distribution
in the UK so pink is the youngest
yeah and yellow is the more elderly this
is median age plotted with nothing to do
with skin color obviously it's just so
all the people tend to be out in the in
the pro in the in the provinces the
youngest in the city so you can see that
that's cities cities are in red so
boroughs and counties in blue so this is
the dementia count like a profile across
all the age ranges it looks like there's
more dementia in the countryside than in
the city but when you do age correction
it brings them nicely overlapping so the
tail off in the in the distribution
there is obviously life expectancy is
about 83 in this country so it tells off
we did age correction in London as well
so dementia seems to map very closely to
the age again
so that's why there was very low
incidence of dementia in the center of
London but when you correct for age
that's what London looks like in terms
of dementia prevalence so quite heavy on
the west side of London and they're
looking at PM 2.5 so this is non-human
made on the left human made seems to
match again quite closely to the wind
professor dark areas on the map on the
left are the wind profile to the highest
wind and in the in the provinces so far
out in Cornwall in Wales in Scotland but
then there's very high levels around the
cities so plotting age adjusted dementia
prevalence for the whole of England it
shows that there's not much of a pattern
okay so plotting a scatter plot again
doesn't show much correlation between
the two so we kind of step back a bit
you know diesel was really only got
popular in 1990 onwards so which age
group is is the most affected it's
probably people from 25 to 44 probably
most of the people in this room so
you've been affected by them by the most
amount of pm10 bibzy 1/5 so the NCI went
five levels luckily on the decline but
the biggest peak was 1990 so anybody
living through that period basically
exposed as much IM sooper and fivers
we're ever going to get in one go
basically so and you can see the
different regulations have come in and
and reduced the by heavy goods vehicles
for example diesel soon will follow
diesel cars will be regulated probably
with congestion charges so if we focus
on the age range only which is which is
going to have been most affected by
diesel emissions yeah I've got a very
got one minute left I have very quick so
yeah we did spot a correlation and so
where there was very low PM 2.5 there
were cases of zero dementia and young
people but it seems to get above a
certain level of missions you start
there are no cases of zero
in case of this convention in each
region so this yeah so that was our main
finding and that's plotted on a map so
you can see it's more focusing over
there this is just the young prevalence
of dementia other things we need to
consider confounders covariates I don't
have time to go through them here but
this is like percentage not born in the
UK this is median household income which
has income has an effect
it's absolutely or a chance of getting
dementia so we did a random for
aggressor model and a whole lot of
features came out biggest importance was
things like education and percent not
born in the UK so quick conclusions we
think there's some indication there's a
link between chelated PM 2.5 and out
early Alzheimer's prevalence at age
between 30 and 40 in that region that
they may be confounded maybe we've got
it wrong because we're not
epidemiologists we're just exploring the
open data but basically what we've seen
we think that just to say it's quite a
challenge to compare open data from
different domains different geographies
have a go with Geo pandas if you can and
we're a data scientist lives
I think after finished class if possibly
a windy place or rainy because rain
actually cleared away all the particles
as well not too much traffic if you have
to live in London then try to hang out
in green areas as much as possible there
are a lot of green areas in London
luckily and get decent sleep eat
healthily get regular exercise and and
just keep learning so that's that's the
perineum do see a chance of dementia so
that's it thank you very much my
question is it not possible this instead
of PM 2.5 in session
noise
the traffic yeah okay so the question is
is it could it be noise and not PM 2.5
alone that's causing dementia yes
somebody mentioned to me yesterday about
noise pollution so I was really
intrigued but that's the first I've
heard about it so yeah the interested
chat afterwards if you have any articles
yeah it's a interesting suggestion I
hadn't thought about it so sure yeah I
think so
okay so just as saying that if it's if
wind is having an impact then it means
it must be something like PM 2.5 is what
you're saying and not noise yeah well
the thing is we focus on London a bit at
the end because the wind levels are
relatively low so it took wind out of
the equation more or less and plus we're
looking at cumulative over five years so
wind effects they today are relatively
minimized so we can't be sure if it's
not noise I don't know we haven't we
hadn't included that I don't know buddy
how you can measure cumulative noise
over a lifetime this book yeah it's
awesome link with early-onset for young
people
but if you're looking in central London
click the young people we know what
proportion of those will have lived in
London for life or some close across
that life yeah it's a huge component in
classes with young people coming in yes
so that's that's another good question
about confounding factors so obviously
in London a lot of people move around
frequently yes so we it was really yeah
it's really hard to deal with that we
found UK government has got listed a lot
of movement statistics between regions
so you could do a really detailed and
thorough analysis because you can it
logs whenever people move from one
region to another at least for the last
I think five or ten years so we could
have started going into that detail but
what we saw was actually if you saw the
plot I think so it's going so young
people tend to live in the centre of
London and then move out so that would
kind of match here because you've got
various surrounding London whither with
a higher young dementia prevalence but
you don't get that out in Cornwall and
Devon and or up in the north of England
for example so maybe that would explain
the movement of people so and you do get
a slight dip in in the dementia right in
the centre of London as well so maybe
explain this movement outwards but yeah
you're right we should really include
that daenerys thorough analysis sorry
yeah obviously got all of the pollution
is it like if there is actually when I
was born elsewhere which is also
polluted by the way I do
valued degrees at opponent I'd like to
hear if we were a group of party makers
UK or wanna continue our decent to just
the next take okay so the gentleman is
mentioning that it's probably had a very
high exposure to PM 2.5 given his age
and weight lived in terms of policy
recommendations while the government is
being asked to produce a strategy for
air quality they tried to get out of it
and move it to after the election that
they've been asked to do it before now I
think I was a court ruling I think
things like diesel cars because they're
easy to do a diesel scrappage scheme is
a good idea so people who live in a very
polluted area they should be
incentivized to get rid of their cars
ideally give everybody a Tesla right but
I don't know it may be a bit expensive
yeah move to Norway is another idea yeah
yeah but yeah and I think trying to
target the sources of the particles is a
good first step is ratification by age
bracket
also stratified by education brackets as
well you mentioned that my son excellent
head office the focus was to avoid
Alzheimer you know practice the muscles
in your brain yep so yeah so the
question is about impact of Education
and intellectual stimulation so yet it's
apparent it's a big factor
more than genetic factors so I guess
coming to conferences like PI data and
you know trying to push your own
learning it's obviously gonna help so
and in terms of our data set yes that's
the next step is to bring in education
level and and there is a lot of data for
that actually so so we found a lot for
the London wards and we'll try and find
the same for the country that's a good
question I'll well we can we can stay in
touch and let you know if you like yeah
sure
[Applause]
[Music]